What we're going to do next is jump into the engine and start utilizing some of these
tools to build a mechanical rig of our own.
We'll be building it for the mech character inside the project, showing off how to set
up a few different control types with their Min and Max settings, setting up the leg with
an IK3 bone function, and showing off how we can get pistons moving in a couple of different
ways.
And then we'll finish off by adding some dynamic movement to our skeletal mesh.
So now would be a great time to open up your project if you want to follow along.
First things first, we need to create a control rig asset.
So inside the project here under the content browser, if we go to meshes and then mech,
and inside here we have our mech mesh.
I'm going to right click, come up to create, and choose control rig.
And then I'm just going to rename this cr underscore my control rig.
And I'll just double click to open that up and dock it in the window here.
Now the first controls we're going to set up will be for our turret here and for the
turret base.
And we're going to use the rotator control type so that they can only rotate.
And then we'll limit the movement of the turret using the min and max settings.
And then once we've got that set up, we'll utilize the FK chain function to actually
connect the controls and the bones together.
To create the two controls, I'm going to select the turret base and main gun.
And you can either use the shortcut control N, or you could right click, come up to new,
and select new control.
And down outside the hierarchy here, what that will do is create a new control for each
thing you have selected.
And it will actually maintain the hierarchy that they have in relation to one another.
So we have the main gun, childhood to the turret base.
So there's two things we want to do now.
We want to change the type of control that this is.
And we want to customize the look of it so that we can see it a little better and it's
a little more user friendly.
So to change the type with both of our controls selected because we want them to both be the
same type.
We're going to come to the details panel and under the value type drop down, change that
to rotator.
And you'll see that under the value heading here, we only have rotation as a min, max
setting that we can set now, as well as seeing the current and initial values, meaning that
these controls are only going to rotate.
And what we can do now is just customize the look of these.
So with the turret base control, let's make that a circle thick.
And I'm just going to click this scale icon to lock all these three axes together.
So when I edit one, they'll all be edited together.
And what I want to do is just keep bringing this up until it's a suitable size.
And that should sort of do us for now.
And with the turret main gun control, if we zoom in on this one, I'm going to make
it a circle thick again.
But if I zoom right there, you can see that it's not really oriented in a very useful
way for us to know how it's going to work when we're rotating it to move this main
gun up and down.
So under the shape transforms here, I'm just going to rotate it 90 along the, I think it's
the y-axis.
Well, let's take a look.
Let's just scale that up to around about 30.
No, so it's not the y-axis.
It's going to be the x-axis that we want.
There we go.
So now this control, we could even go a touch bigger.
Now this control indicates that it's going to rotate in this axis just because of the
way that it's facing.
So what I'm going to do here to make sure that we limit it from moving in any other
axis is select the control either from the viewport or from the rig hierarchy window
and come up to the min-max settings here.
And we know we only want to rotate this gun up and down in the y-axis.
So what I'm going to do is activate the minimum for the x and z-axis, leave those at zero,
and do the same for the max, but set them to zero as well.
And this will mean that it won't be able to rotate in those two axes.
So you can see now if I move them, nothing's happening.
We also know that we want to set some min-max of our y-axis so that when we rotate it downwards,
it doesn't pass through the main turret base here.
Now I know what those values are, but just to show you the process of how we kind of
figured those out, I'm first going to restrict the axes that the turret base control can
move in, and then I'll connect them up to the bones to see how they're actually affecting
our mesh.
So we just want to rotate in the z-axis.
So what I'm going to do under the min, I'm going to activate the x and the y, and leave
them at zero, and do the same for the max, again setting those to zero as well.
So now if we were to connect these up using an FK chain, which we'll do now, we should
be able to see how our controls are acting.
So I'm going to select these two controls, drag them in and choose create item array.
I'll just minimize that for now and plug that into the controls array pin on the FK chain.
And then I'll come back to the top and find the two bones, do the same thing with those,
drag those in, create item array, and I'll plug those into the bones pin.
Now it's important that you select these in the right order, and that you have the turret
base and the turret base in the same element number, and the main gun and main gun at the
same element number.
And when I connect up the logic, what we should see is that we can rotate this up and down,
and our gun moves up and down.
And if we rotate this along the z-axis, we can actually rotate the body of our gun.
And we're not able to rotate an x or y for this, and the same with the actual gun itself.
We can only rotate in the y, not the z or the x.
Now if this gun section was part of the mesh that needed to be super accurate in terms
of how many degrees it could rotate up and down, that's likely something that's been
calculated when you were creating the mesh.
So you'd know how many degrees to limit your rotation in the Minimax settings already.
But for us, I'm just going to do this by eye and round the figures to the nearest point
five.
And to do this, if I come towards the control here and just take a look closer at our mesh,
I'm going to open the current tab under the transform heading.
And as we move this, you'll see that that value gets updated.
So what I'm going to say is as we rotate down, maybe we don't want to go any more than something
like six degrees there.
Or maybe we could go touch further.
Yeah, maybe we could go about nine degrees.
So that would be our minimum offset.
And our maximum, we just want to pull that up ever so slightly.
I think from the previous testing, it's around about two and a half degrees.
So I'm going to come to our Min setting here and activate the Y and set that to minus nine.
And under the max, set that to 2.5.
So now when I select this and try to rotate it, it'll come down all the way to nine degrees.
And then it won't actually let me go any further.
And the same when I'm going up.
So it's now locked to this range of motion.
So if you do have a range of motion, a specific number of degrees that something should rotate in,
this is how you'd set up those values.
So that's how we would go about setting a rotator type control and setting up the min and max axis,
min and max values, should I say, on each axis.
Next, we'll take a look at the IK3 bone function and set up one of the legs for this mech.